well merry little Christmas yes I read
it's inspired by true events you must
explain yes so basically what ended up
happening is my family moved into our
home a new home and we were so excited
and I was so excited I was like we
should have the whole family here and so
my husband's like no that's not a good
idea he's like he already knew like
something could possibly happen and so
basically our whole family got in we
baked cookies in the whole process of
baking the cookies of my nieces decided
to redecorate my brand-new cream chairs
with red and green icing and another
family member decided that it would make
much more sense to spill you know
coca-cola all over my brand-new $10,000
rug it was a whole bunch of series it
was a series of events that happen and
basically I ended up talking to one of
the execs at lifetime about it and she
said oh we have to at that movie well we
work some of it and like have it a part
of the roster for all the Christmas
Lifetime movies and I said okay so
that's exactly what happened yeah Jackie
Jackie little a professional
Jackie is an OCD tech entrepreneur
perfectionist yes
is Kelly like that Kelly is very much so
OCD
oh I talks about myself as third person
but yes I am I am very much so OCD yes
well so so you drew your character
directly from my life absolutely so do
you speak to your family now what what
does Christmas like now at your house oh
my gosh Christmas is nice and quiet at
my house with myself my husband and my
son but I do miss having my family there
it's the just a warm feeling of family
there and everyone being all under one
roof and the fireplace and smelling
something baking or cooking or laughter
it's just that whole feeling of
Christmas is the best what's it like is
it different now that you have
son I mean that's gotta be a great age
for Christmas it is the best age for
Christmas because it's the excitement
that he feels especially now I think he
really gets Christmas because the other
day he found the little elf the Elf on a
shelf and he said mommy who is that
again I said it's Elf on the Shelf he
said and he thought about his behavior
he's like I have to be a good boy I said
yeah but you're a good boy he's like
yeah but I have to be a good boy mommy
and I said you're a great boy so yeah
he's thinking about his behavior and
what he's gonna get for Christmas and
what he wants for Christmas but we're
teaching him actually about the spirit
of giving so it's the first like real
lesson he's had about it and basically
what ended up happening is he went
through his toys that he no longer
really plays with and I was like you
know some of these like aren't even open
I was like and there are some kids who
don't have any toys and so I said
wouldn't it feel good to give someone
some toys and he said he thought about
it he says okay he puts together a pile
of all these toys I'm Newsome a little
bit old and once he sees the POW he
starts crying and I said what's the
matter he said I'm gonna miss my toys so
much and I said it's okay I said but you
have to think about the fact that it
takes a really big boy to be able to
give so much that's one I said in to
think about how happy the kid that's
going to be you know to receive all
these awesome toys you gave them and
he's still cried but he eventually
understood but it's a really important
lesson in our household well that's a
great lesson in what are some Christmas
traditions that you're gonna teach him
or you know that you practice now with
your family I know one thing that we've
started to do every year especially
since the birth of Titan is a charity
that I'm actually really close to baby
to baby we do big Christmas gala every
year and have different families by kids
and other families like their Christmas
so we basically support like as many
families as you would like to support of
course you buy their Christmas and
you're able to your family is able to
give the family their Christmas and it's
the best feeling in the world that's one
of the things I'm so looking forward to
this Christmas to share with my son
I'm also looking forward to cooking with
my son looking forward to sharing my mom
who's passed on like her recipes with my
son and watching Christmas movies you
know what I mean like the the fun warm
cozy stuff what Christmas movies are
your home alone is to go to home alone
is to go to the Family Stone is one of
my favorites elf is definitely a
favorite and yeah all these Christmas
movies that we're about to embark on
with it's a wonderful life time we're
going to keep life time on of course -
of course of course I'm gonna watch with
my family I've already called and told
my family that this was happening and
they were like okay like we can't wait
to see it so yeah I can't believe it's
been 20 years since you know writings on
the wall mm-hmm and people still love
the music yes how does it feel for you
like to know that people still hold you
guys in such with such warmth and high
regard ice a blessing it's definitely a
blessing the loyalty and love behind it
is it just makes you grateful super
grateful that after 20 years an album
and a body of work and we can be so well
received it's truly grateful now there
were rumors earlier this year that there
might be a
sushant reunion tour I haven't heard
anything about it I talked to the girls
all the time we talk about kids or a
night out or no that hasn't come up in
conversation really no so those rumors
were not true those were just what they
are they're just rumors